what is happening reject nation greg and
john
on my left i'm on your left
on screen right but you're left
we're gonna watch today from uh good
morning america's
eric voss here new rock stars breakdown
of falcon and winter soldier
episode two as the information is just
getting juicier i'm like
we gotta pick this back up as we missed
last week's
and we're probably going to miss next
week because we won't be around
at least catch episode two today let's
get into this
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
falcon of the winter soldier episode 2
the star-spangled man in which nearly
every avenger gets a mention
even avengers the government didn't want
us to know about i'm going to break down
this episode for all the interesting
details that you might have justice for
isaiah last episode i pointed out how
the opening close-ups of sam irony in
that black suit gave us some major
funeral vibes as sam did hope to
entomb cap's shield in the museum
similarly with the close-up of that
zipper going down like a body bag
opening up to reveal a corpse inside
which metaphorically it is kind of the
corpse of steve rogers legacy
sam wanted to lay it to rest john walker
is kind of frankensteining it back to
life
in quite an unnatural way this whole
locker room takes a sympathetic picture
of walker
everybody in the world expects me
to be something and i don't want to fail
them
good morning america hey i get you john
good morning america can be fun
i hope eric vos takes as much
opportunity as possible to keep
consistently reminding us that he has
graduated to the big leagues
of going on good morning america you
disney shill
yeah yeah you worldwide celebrity
leaving us all in the dust over here to
collect those mouse checks
but you were great on there it was good
good appearance great appearance really
really happy for you sincerely can we
can we join you next time
walker's buddy here is lamar hoskins aka
battle star so in the comics john walker
started as super patriot
kind of an [ __ ] replacement cap and
he's accompanied by bold urban commandos
or
buckies including huskins walker ends up
getting the cap title he goes crazy
kills a bunch of people and eventually
the government makes him
u.s agent whose uniform actually looks a
lot like what walker wears here this
episode makes it seem like they could
have decent intentions despite
clues pointing otherwise two weeks ago
we're prepping the team for a special
ops mission and chile about this
a lot of handshakes a lot of suits a lot
of
speeches and senator meetings now
remember bucky just busted
senator atwood over hydra operative
which seemed like a one-off thing
except the end credits included a
missable headline about senator atwood
border enforcement i don't know maybe
this senator was pushing walker to round
up border crossers and then that mission
in chile
the last time we saw a special ops team
in south america it was led by
a super soldier who
also might be behind all of this his
name appeared in the end credits with a
mention of
enhanced humans act now hoskins mentions
and the marching band music is that same
star spangled man with a plan
from cap's warbonne store in the first
cap film
yeah this is all a modern version of
that same original cat publicity tour
down to signing collectibles
custer's grove high school custer's
grove is the hometown of john walker in
the comics it's also where the extremist
group the watchdogs try to kill walker
and then end up getting his parents
killed
making him go berserk the gma
interviewer says the government did a
study of your body at mit
and you tested off the charts in every
measurable category
speed endurance intelligence look here's
the thing
i'm not tony stark i'm not dr banner and
we see shots of him with a punching bag
recalling cap with a punching bag and
avengers
shield a shield that he would have just
gotten meaning his coordination must be
abnormally good that might actually be
why walker cuts
her off when she is talking about his
freaky physiology
i think he and hoskins might have
already been given super soldier serum i
think it's likely that he's got some
super soldier serum just because even in
the fight scenes and the shield itself
was something that we were talking about
during the review part of our reaction
i feel like you'd have to be so
incredibly precise yeah
to be able to handle that that being
said you know you do see
in the trailers elites falcon practicing
with the shield at 1.2 and he doesn't
have any super soldier strength so
there's a way to do it
but i i i think like even with the truck
fight sequence and all that
there's nothing there that that could
that confirms and like yeah you can get
away in the world of marvel
that could you could just be a human but
there's still
stuff that indicates of maybe it's
starting to kick in now
you know yeah yeah or maybe they've
developed some kind of updated serum
because doesn't somebody also in the
episode make a crack
about the super soldier serum itself
being like risky or outdated or
something so like i wouldn't be
surprised at all if they haven't
revealed that yeah john walker and
hoskins both have some kind of
enhancements yeah
interesting how walker's suit design
positions the a with wings logo so that
it bleeds over onto the shoulder strap
so that the look is only complete if he
is suited up perfectly
unlike steve rogers who was able to rip
his logo off his shoulder and still
function in the suit
this guy is a manufactured hero
restrained by the government he has to
represent
[ __ ] damn great
visual pick up there the big three
white pick three android gm
ultron aliens for thanos and his army
wizards presumably for loki i mean sam
wasn't part of the avengers yet but
remember loki learned his sorcery from
friega and asgardian witch
i mean i don't think it matters if
falcon was a part of the adventures
i mean i feel like you could have
learned the information absolutely
like common knowledge also this does
take place
five months after one division sam could
be also referencing the threat of the
witches of west view which is gonna come
back to them see you in multiverse
madness i love that he says
so who are you fighting now gandalf yep
how do you know about gandalf
i read the hobbit in 1937 when it first
came out
yeah bucky just checked him with uh i
understood that reference he's such a
nerd i
love it i mean one thing i find
interesting about this is
this series is supposed to come out
first and the fact that it's coming out
second
fixes the timeline events if he is
indeed referring to the events from one
division
yeah because i'm like wait wouldn't that
have been confusing for audiences
back then if they went in the original
release date order
yeah yeah yeah and if it was a reference
to that then it's like you would only be
able to pick it up
afterwards yeah like the
and then after staring contest on the
plane they argue enjoy your ride buck no
you can't call me that
why not that's what steve called you
steve knew me longer and steve had a
plan
what is it
only captain calling buck just like
scott lang with cap only friends are in
the one syllable club now being the man
of the play is really the key here
the titular song in this episode is that
captain america was the star
spangled man with the plan on the
avengers cap was really the one who
called the shots he always had the plan
so really the conflict among these four
cap successors is as much over who has
the best plan
as it is as whoever has the shield sam's
plan here it's kind of what captain and
captain america winter soldier just dive
out of a plane without a shoot i love
how bucky's like yeah yeah i can do it
but then he
definitely gets coverage about it and
falls pretty hilarious as they snoop on
the flag smashers sam says
little time in wakanda and you come out
white panther it's actually white wolf
huh yeah remember after civil war bucky
rested in wakanda
and in black panther local wakandan kids
nicknamed him the
white horse white wolf aka hunter is a
separate character in the comics leading
the wakandan secret police
bucky owns up to this title despite not
really gearing up until the battle of
wakanda in infinity war
so in what other ways did he assist
shuri in t'challa to earn this title
flagsmaster carly morgenthau is played
by aaron kellyman the cloud writer in
this nest and solo
that's where she's from oh there you go
in the comics
and she is strong she breaks red wing
but if you think about it this actually
does sam a favor
since he finds out after this that the
government had hacked into that drone
to spy on all of his movements i just
gotta say it broke my heart when red
wing died i agree
that uh i justice for redwing justice
for red wing
you see it in my reaction i have a
moment
where i'm like i feel like red wing's
gonna get real personality in this
episode
and then two minutes later he's just
annihilated
like no i thought he was gonna have like
a droid friend
ah posthumous personality only in the
morning
does the red wing now have a personality
that really uh
bummed me out i feel like you got to get
rid of wing back in some way
well you know red wing will come back
you know like rework it'll become a new
ultron it'll grow into this whole other
side
it's just funny to me because i was so
lost in thought about
red wing actually being obliterated that
i did not pick up on that detail at all
about oh actually you know what that
that's a good thing
that helped out and that helps out
without it without
uh i'm realizing and i was so caught up
and i can't believe red wing's gone
see it works out that's why it was
glitchy before and that's probably where
they heard the phrase the big three now
the truck license plates are an impact
that's good
and 2011 ekh now 2011 ekh is actually
the same tag number as the one on wanda
maximoff's rental in one division
episode eight there's the third another
hex
marvel comics universe where cap is gone
not sure about that one but then cap
walker drops in
yeah the composer henry jackman worked
in a light motif to captain america's
theme it sounds like cap's promise from
civil war now bucky has to dodge the
shield when walker throws it it looks
like walker did not care if he was gonna
hit bucky in the face
but later in this fight bucky catches
the shield with his normal man
back to walker and not to his dramatic
catch winner
hey watch where you throw that thing cap
there's a moment where walker pulls out
his gun and shoots a flag smasher
now i know cap used a gun in world war
ii and even sam here uses red wing to
fire on him but it
is just weird to see like a foreign gun
yeah
using a firearm on people sam and bucky
conclude these flag smashers must be
super soldiers which seems to come as
news to the other guys and we're pretty
sure it's one of the big three
so aliens and georgia wizards there's no
such thing as wizards
all right then it's aliens or androids
or super soldiers okay super soldiers
for real
yeah wow yeah so
either walker and hoskins are really dim
or they know full well that the flag
smashers are enhanced super soldiers
because
these two came from the same enhancement
program that power broker the flag
smashers are ripping off
could be the power broker who enhanced
walker and hoskins in the comics and
interestingly later
joaquin torres turning him into the next
falcon wait what
i don't know about that that's right
everybody i'll
oh it's sweet he's gonna stick around
he's got to stick around the show i mean
wrong in that first episode i was
worried he was gonna die oh
damn oh you could become the next falcon
in some way well and he did take like an
extraordinary beating in that episode so
that suggests too that he's probably got
things
planned for the future i think he eric
is probably right about this whole thing
with the power
if indeed that battle star and and uh
new fake captain already have the super
soldier serum
in them because especially the way they
were focusing on the power broker
character the way it was shot was
emphasizing this moment of i don't know
this person
yeah i don't care about this person yet
but i feel like this person is going to
be like vitally important to your story
and how this all unfolds later they seem
like they were kind of prepared for
something that was a little bit more
heightened
yeah granted you know you've got bucky
and sam who have experience on this
level but they didn't seem
vexed or or thrown at all by the amount
of force coming back at them so yeah and
that little
little look from john walker before he's
like oh really
like i could definitely see some uh some
truths being hidden
walker says he jumped on a grenade
before like kat but walker says he used
a reinforced helmet
see his training is a manufactured
replica of the real thing that steve
went through because steve jumped on
that grenade assuming he would die they
bring up the grc
global repatriation council an agency
that manages resources for returning
blip refugees
this could be what thaddeus ross now
heads up because here he could use this
new team of super soldiers to keep the
peace internationally because we know
ross has been trying to build a team
like that for a long time back to the
early days of the incredible hulk
and then maybe these flag smashers could
have been past super soldiers who
escaped
when the blip happened and stalled
ross's plans it's all connected they
provide the resources we keep expanding
violent revolutionaries aren't usually
good for anyone's cause usually say
about the people with the resources ooh
sounds like sam's drinking that flag
smasher kool-aid his bank
denial reminded him resources are not
fairly distributed you know what i gotta
point out too
especially with daddy's ross i feel like
that might be the big reason why they
finally caved it on black widow
yeah i don't know why they have to like
release it in order to keep
this bigger larger story going because
they've been hinting
at you know the super villain types of
teams for so long with the fact that
zemo's coming in we've been hearing the
talks of
thaddeus ross coming into the fold and
it just seemed like it was only a matter
of time
until then otherwise i'm going to feel
bad for all the theorists at this point
[Laughter]
the rest about that is coming in and
here's what they're building too
never going to amount to anything more
the thunderbirds and all that
jazz and yeah like daddy's ross is in
the credit like how he pointed out
earlier in this video thaddeus ross
indeed being in the credit sequence so
they want you to still be aware of him
yeah a hundred percent
and with zemo being here i i just think
that
they're like okay we have to release
black widow yeah because
because now the timeline of events yeah
you know now we're at the point where we
can't remix things and keep things clear
for the audience yeah
100 that's just interesting and i hope
the thaddeus frosting starts actually
coming into play otherwise
yeah that's just been theorizing about
this for so long
to get excited about that surprise
character in trophy
for the show at least and then walker
says i'm just trying to be
the best captain america i can be i'll
very us
army be all that you can be but then he
blows it it'd be a whole lot easier
if i had caps wingmen on my side
it's always that last line by belittling
sam is merely cap's wingman he totally
misunderstands the partnership between
sam
and kat we also learned that sharon
carter who's also gonna be returning
this show was like the rest of them
labeled a criminal for stealing their
gear in civil war and then sam meets
this kid
falcon kid my daddy told me it's black
falcon
because i'm black and i'm the falcon
technically
so are you like black kid yes comics
have a history of using characters race
in their name like black goliath
what never heard of this before what
race black lighting are clearly
black panther later with this awful
encounter with the cops
so isaiah bradley here we go black
captain america introduced in 2003.
his history was erased he was one of the
300 black test subjects
which we get a hint at the end credits
and most of those test subjects died it
was really based on the way the
government
in real life gave black men syphilis in
the tuskegee experiments
really [ __ ] up now in the comics
isaiah's grandson is elijah bradley
non-nova avenger patriot and the kid who
answers the door is labeled in the brain
it's
like bradley elijah
that's a great way to indicate
the future of that character it's like
everything they've been talking about
with building the young avengers
yeah yeah oh that is wonderful like that
confirmation having it right there in
the credits
that is clever yeah that is super clever
yeah cause i thought that was just a
theory and someone said in the
conference that's got to be eli bradley
and then
i didn't even catch it in the credits oh
how wonderful yes
how wonderful yeah we're gonna be
getting ourselves a patriot we are
and notice his reaction when isaiah
snaps i'm not gonna talk about it
anymore
yeah in the young admissions comics
eli's powers are later revealed to just
be him juicing up with a mutant growth
hormone he actually does not have
natural powers
so here this might be him wishing he had
that kind of strength isaiah
wedges that tin in the wooden frame it's
actually similar to how sam will
later wedge the shield into the wood of
a tree it's kind of like for these guys
the legacy of cap doesn't allow them to
bounce off obstacles like teflon they
just get stuck in it
isaiah reveals the awful history of how
the government treated him you know what
they did
to me for being a hero they put my ass
in jail for 30 years
people running tests
taking my blood coming into my cell
even your people weren't done with me
and by bucky's people he meant
hydra meaning hydra might have derived
their own super soldier serum cocktail
from
isaiah's blood you know it would be
pretty
daring it wouldn't end on a positive
note that's for sure
but it would be pretty daring if they
decided to do
like a a movie about isaiah bradley that
would be awe i mean
i'll just see them do that i know it's a
little too bold for
what disney does people who want to
switch their brain off when they go to
the superhero man
yeah and i already saw the comments a
few people who already are like
like the things we were all saying that
they would start doing and then they
start doing like oh to keep your
politics out of my captain america show
my historically political character
i know it would definitely rile up some
feathers there if they did an isaiah
bradley movie but
seeing this character here i'm like i i
love
like the idea of i mean like you you
only get hints
of what that must have been and the
power of isaiah bradley's story right
there and i think it would be cool to
just get a movie
oh yeah dude do it dude let's get a
petition going sign it and then after
that
a red wing movie
it'll be an animated movie it'll be like
a computer animator for kids
after they get arrested walker gets
bucky out bucky's not going to be
following a strict schedule
any longer we haven't finished our work
who authorizes um
the biggest douche of balmor as when he
threw that shield at bucky's head he
does not care about bucky's well-being
only how he can use him
and after leaving therapy bucky asks dr
raynor what was rule number two again
don't hurt anyone yeah bucky needed this
reminder as he goes off to face zemo
another name on his men's list whom i'm
sure he wants to hurt very badly the
flag smasher's gotta scramble
how much time do we have no it's about i
was i was wondering why he asked that
did i get that and again
i think he is linked to that same whole
history of human enhancement that walker
and hoskins and thaddeus ross could be
involved in
we end the episode in this german prison
facility that zemo was left in and he is
in cell
2187 which is a nod to star wars cell
2187
that's great it was a short film 2187
that inspired george lucas to make thx
that's great and star wars keeps
bringing this number back like later
finn's designation was
fn2187 mozart's requiem plays and then
we see the chess set which actually kind
of acts like that magneto's imprisonment
in the x-men movies but like that super
villain this guy
i don't think will be in prison for much
longer actually there was something
about
the classical music and cutting to him
that made me think of
um when you see wilson fisk and
daredevil season
two is where my mom went with that but
then again it is a little bit of a
trophy thing villain with classic music
yeah
music to enhance the irony of the
situation hey to celebrate the series we
have our new latest obsession shirt
anarchy i gotta get another shirt
follow me on instagram and twitter davos
follow new rockstars and subscribe to
rockstars here on youtube for deep dives
and everything marvel thanks for
watching
fun stuff that's great man great i love
how it's all tying in and i'm excited
for that
like that is ross has been the slowest
damn build-up in the mcu i've ever seen
daddy followed by the young avengers
they're sprinkling kids in all along the
way now
this is thaddeus himself like he shows
up in incredible hulk doesn't show back
up again until freaking captain america
civil war
he's mentioned here he's in the black
widow trailer using black little
trailers at the funeral for i think in
uh yeah is it the funeral nine game
so you're like there's so much story to
tap into with him
you've got a veteran actor though
there's something there
it's gonna be happening i'm nervous
there's a lot of comic story lines and i
think it's actually coming true
i think so i think it's actually
happening and they're really kicking it
off with this series in particular and
yeah it just makes sense to tie it in
you know like
i think it's great like with from the
super soldiers and the government rules
and having thaddeus come in specifically
with civil war
and tying his story back around and i
think it's going to bleed into she-hulk
in some way has to
yeah and black widow like daddy is i
think i think people are not
realizing just how pivotal
of a character that he is ross is going
to be uh
going forward people are kind of
underestimating it i think
yeah man we need our we need our hayward
for the rest of the you know mcu series
well it becomes like red hulk and
they're in the super soldier serum and
like
there's there's a lot to unpack here but
i'm loving this show i'm excited
i think it's just gonna get heavier and
heavier as we go only six episodes so
it's gonna just get a lot more weighty
as we keep going exactly what's in store
guys leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button
see you guys sometime next week
[Music]